Famously Greenland was settled by the Vikings
and I just ran into the first guy here
who looks like a Viking, Nicky.
You look like a Viking.
You also look like a clean-up hitter
for the Boston Red Sox.
Okay.
Yeah.
What?
Oh, you can buy a gun here?
But there's no gun violence here.
(audience laughs)
Wait, you walked for three days?
Yeah.
What are you, Johnny Appleseed?
What are you --
(audience laughs)
Well you don't need to.
It's a very funny reference
and people in my country will laugh,
and people in your country won't see this.
Yeah.
Here's the point,
you walked for three days, why?
(audience laughs)
So next time you go for a walk for three days,
do you think you'll--
Sure, I'll come.
Do we bring any food with us?
And just eat it raw on the side of the road?
Have you eaten a raw deer?
You ate a raw liver of a reindeer.
Well, yeah, you're not an animal.
(audience laughs)
This is incredible, you are, you have true Viking blood.
Oh, you think I would pass for Viking?
You think I seem manly enough to to be a Viking?
(audience laughs)
Fix what?
When I'm talking about me now?
Why fix something?
What do you mean?
(audience laughs)
Soon after my arrival I was interviewed by KNR,
Greenland's biggest and only television station.
Hi, how are you?
How are you?
I'm good, I was just wandering in these rocks.
Yeah, isn't it beautiful?
Beautiful and I saw you doing a story
and I thought I'd come over.
Well it felt like a really fun opportunity
to come here and meet everybody,
and if I come here as part of my show,
I don't have to pay for it.
(audience laughs)
The show pays for it.
So this is a free trip for me, yeah.
(audience laughs)
It's the first country to sell for that much.
The golf course.
You have a golf course.
It's called the Golf Klub.
(audience laughs)
(audience laughs and cheers)
Who do
inspired the most?
Wow, it's hard to say.
I mean, I've been inspired by so many people.
The Kellogg Family.
I think his name is William Kellogg.
You know he was the first person to make breakfast cereal.
I had not a always happy childhood,
and one of the things I took solace in was sugar cereals.
Your Cocoa Krispies, your Captain Crunch,
your Captain Crunch with Crunch Berries,
(audience laughs)
Cocoa Puff, anything with chocolate in it,
and Marshmallows Lucky Charms, Kellogg's did a lot of that,
(audience laughs)
and so they actually influenced my childhood,
and they're one of the reasons today
that I can't lift things above my shoulder.
(audience laughs)
Because it's not good for you, yeah.
The next stop on my Greenland press tour
was an interview and photo shoot
with the CEO of Greenland's biggest and only airline.
Jacob, thank you for having me to your wonderful country.
Thank you for coming here.
I very much enjoy your airline.
It has long been my dream
to be in an in-flight magazine.
Yeah?
I've always wanted to be in an in-flight magazine.
And I've tried and tried and tried,
got very close with Virgin Atlantic once,
and then they found out that I was a virgin.
(audience laughs)
They thought that was bad publicity.
What's been your impression of Greenland
and the Greenland people?
This is a stunning country, absolutely beautiful.
Also, and I'm gonna go out on a limb here,
but I'm gonna say that no country I've ever been to
has better dried fish.
You guys kill it with dried fish.
(audience laughs)
I don't know what you do,
but no one dries a fish like you guys.
And what a great way to experience fish.
Yeah.
You know, you can keep the fish in your wallets.
You can keep then in a fanny pack.
(audience laughs)
You can use the dried pressed fish as a bookmark,
and then when you're done with the book,
you can eat the bookmark, the fish.
It's amazing.
I see people walking around.
They trade them like old baseball cards.
(audience laughs)
I don't know who's out there
with a blow dryer on the beach,
but I think you're just doing an amazing job.
Oh, excellent, thank you, Conan.
And before I knew it, I was back at KNR Studios
to lend a little star power to their nightly broadcast.
Please keep in mind, this really aired
all across Greenland.
Good evening, I'm Conan O'Brien,
and I'm bringing you the latest weather report
(audience cheers and claps)
for Greenland.
I will give the report in the Greenlandic language
'cause let's face it, how hard could it be?
(audience laughs)
(audience laughs and cheers)
There's cold stuff coming.
(audience claps and cheers)